هجول هجول بكم كثيره هي الرسائل التي
حملها احتفال حركه حماس في الذكرى الخامسه
والثلاثين لانطلاقتها
[موسيقى]
فقد كان مناسبه للتاكيد على ثوابت الحركه
رغم كل التحديات التي اعترضت مسيرته
لكن قائد الحركه في قطاع غزه يحيى السنوار
او لهتماما ملموسا لقضيه الاسرى عندما كشف
عن فشل جولات مفاوضات سريه مع اسرائيل
لاتمام صفقه جزئيه لتبادل الاسرى تكون
مقدمه
لصفقه شامله على غرار صفقه شاليه
وقتا محدودا لاتمامها
فاخر العدو الاربعه طرف المقاومه الى ابد
الابدين
وبغرض تحريك ملف اسرع عرضت وحده الظل
التابعه لكتائب القسام قطعه سلاح قالت
انها لضابط اسرائيلي اسرته خلال حرب عام
من الرسائل التي وجهها السنوار لاطراف
خارجيه وداخليه فقد حذر من تحديات
الاستراتيجيه كبرى ستعترض مسيره الشعب
الفلسطيني خلال العام المقبل قال انه لا
سبيل لمواجهتها الا بالوحده الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه وهو المطلب نفسها الذي تضمنته
كلمه صوتيه مسجله لقائد كتائب القسام محمد
الضيف
وتتوحد كل الرايات
وتلتئم كل الجبهات ولتفتح كل الساحات لهدف
واحد غايه كبيره نبيله مقدسه وهي تحرير
فلسطين رسائل حركه حماس ومطالبها تاتي في
ظل مرحله حساسه وتطورات محليه واقليميه
متوتره
فالاوضاع في القدس والضفه الغربيه تبدو
مرشحه للتصعيد بفعل السياسه الاسرائيليه
تجاه الفلسطينيين هنا
وفي ضوء هذه الاوضاع يترقب كثيرون طبيعه
التطورات الميدانيه في المرحله المقبله ول
دحدوح الجزيره غزه فلسطين